science shows like the only cat i know
talking about the uh
the ethiopia uh genocide that's
happening in the tigrit region i didn't
even know that was a thing [ __ ] this is
what i'm talking about you but you knew
about the gaza and free palestine [ __ ]
because all the celebrities writing
letters but there's literally a genocide
happening right now and nobody's talking
about it because because there's no
special because because nip ain't here
like does nipple talk about it well yeah
well i mean to be fair like one there's
not a ethiopian celebrity besides nip
right um
who
is like on the forefront of the culture
exactly i think ruby rose might be
ethiopian yeah scishow talks about it
but not like and also too like i feel
like
you know
low-key like the us only gets involved
in those kind of
things that benefit them like yeah like
what are the numbers so what's over what
are the streams what are the streams
what kind of what kind of natural
resources are in ethiopia so we could go
and help out yeah
that is that is america they're just
like all right yeah we're down to look
good here put a military base here [ __ ]
i like all this [ __ ]
oh they got poppy fields over there
right right
oh they got oil over there
oh
they got money over there
that's great i didn't know there was a
genocide happening yeah nobody's talking
about it please talk about it please
spread the word there is a yeah there is
a humanitarian issue happening in the
atria i'm sorry not even you know it's
not easter get that out of my face it's
ethiopia in the tigre region yeah
they're starving
was was
just like tiffany had she's atrium
there's a big history in population in
l.a but uh
but yeah this is this is ethiopia and
the tegra region it's like that's just
been going since november so before the
israel and palestine conflict that
happened again in gaza and all these
[ __ ] wrote letters but then it's like
okay there's still another one happening
over here bro you know like are we
picking and choosing the the holocaust
we're supporting now
that's wild yeah i didn't know that like
if yeah if like if this genocide was
sponsored by like you know taco bell and
red bull [ __ ] be like okay cool can i
livestream down on hulu what's up
yeah you know it's a lot of this fake
woke [ __ ] man [ __ ] what's that popular
[ __ ] it's what i'm saying
so what we talking about again uh i
don't remember what we were talking
about top five genocides top five
genocides of all time